لجيفارا البديري جيفارا كنت تتحدثين قبل
قليل ان هناك معلومات عن
اقتحام لنابلس والان اتاكد حسب هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه ان هناك قوه اسرائيليه بالفعل
تقوم بعمليه عسكريه في نابلس ماذا نعرف
عنها
[موسيقى]
حتى الان هناك فقط دوريات لجيش الاحتلال
تتواجد في منطقه سهل عسكر اي قريب من مخيم
عسكر في مدينه نابلس لا يوجد حتى اللحظه
اقتحام حقيقي فقط هناك تواجد لدوريات
تابعه لقوات الاحتلال ايضا حول ما يحدث في
جنين اذا لا نستطيع حتى الان ان نعرف ماذا
يحدث في نابلس ولكن التاكيدات حتى اللحظه
وفق شهود العيان لا يوجد اقتحام فقط تواجد
لدوريات الاحتلال ايضا وفق مصادر
اسرائيليه بدات تراجع عن ان كان منفذ
عمليه حواره هو من بين من تم اغتيالهم في
داخل المنزل وان كان اصلا صحيح ما قاله
وبسطته اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه تم
اغتيال اربعه مسلحين فلسطينيين في داخل
المنزل الذي لا زال محاصرا من قبل وحدات
خاصه وازرع لقوات سواء الشباك او حرس
الحدود وازرع مختلفه
لكل قوات الاحتلال في المنطقه لا زالت على
ما يبدو قوات الاحتلال تقوم بالعمليه
العسكريه وانت تتحدثين نبث الان الصور
لدخول القوات الاسرائيليه انت لم تسميها
عمليه اقتحام ولكن يبدو ان قوات اسرائيليه
دخلت سهل عسكر في نابلس هذه اولى الصور
لعمليه دخول القوات الاسرائيليه لسهل عسكر
في نابلس تفضلي
نعم بالفعل كما ذكرت لك دخول للدوريات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الى منطقه سهل عسكر
نحن بانتظار ولكن هناك مصادر محليه تتحدث
عن اعتقال شاب من عماره محاصره في المنطقه
الشرقيه في نابلس ولكن كما ذكرت لك لا شيء
مؤكد حتى اللحظه لا يوجد تاكيد لا يوجد
شيء في نابلس هو فقط تواجد لبعض الدوريات
ولكن حتى الان لا يوجد اي اقتحام لمنطقه
نابلس الحديث لا زال حسب قوات الاحتلال هو
عمليه عسكريه موسعه في مخيم جنين ومحيطه
ونذكر هنا مجددا بان العمليه العسكريه تمت
في وضح النهار كما تمت مجزره نابلس قبل
اسبوعين يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال وصلتها
معلومات كما كانت قد تحدثت الاسبوع الماضي
عن وصول معلومات لمنفذه
منفذ او منفذي عمليه قتل مستوطن في منطقه
عقبه جبر في اريحا وعندما تم الوصول الى
هناك واعتقال عدد من الشبان اكتشف لاحقا
بان المعلومات كانت خاطئه لانه تم الافراج
عن هؤلاء